i'm joined now by our own christina
rafini she's been here at the polish
border covering the refugee crisis we
keep talking about women and children
leaving the war zone but they're still
helping back home aren't they they are
and just by being here they're helping
it was actually a young ukrainian man
who told us that by bringing their
children out by bringing civilians out
they are helping the military be able to
focus on what they need to do by taking
civilians out of the way they've also
been acting as couriers we've seen women
with eu tagged cars that can go back
across across the border or go anywhere
in europe running in to get family and
then this weekend we met a young woman
she's 29 years old she worked in
journalism and communications she was
here for about 30 minutes we followed
her across the border she went and
picked up a car that was full of night
vision goggles it had sleeping bags it
had antibiotics all kinds of supplies
and she took the keys and she was
driving it to the front to donate it to
the ukrainian military she said look i
don't have a gun i can't fire a gun i
can't fight but this is what i can do
and so this is how i'm volunteering to
help everyone helping in their own way
christine ruffini great reporting once
again